foreign
[Music]
Journey with Selena began
oh gosh that was a while ago
um
in 2015 my sister
started managing Selena Gomez and told
me that you'll never believe this Selena
Gomez is a giant fan of Truth or Dare
that was like she is it's so long for
her time
um
and so I met with her and I was you know
very Charmed by her she was very
authentic and unlike most pop stars are
certainly Superstars which she already
was in a sense
she had no guile she had no no Persona
per se
and I was really taken aback by that
because in my
during the course of my career I've met
a lot of
um relatively famous people
and usually especially on a first
meeting you can sense that they have a
certain armor up
so I did a music video with her then
when she was getting ready to do her
tour
she came back and said would you ever do
a truth or dare for for me and I said I
don't think that's really something
I I should do or that you should do
really at 24 and
um
and she kind of persisted and I said
look I go I really had an insanely
unique experience with Madonna she let
me film everything I was allowed access
to everything I just shot I didn't have
to go through assistance I didn't have
to knock on doors
and she goes I'll give you that I'll
give you that so
you know I said okay why don't we try a
two-week run because you may think we're
gonna you're gonna be okay with that but
I'm not sure you're you're gonna find it
that comfortable
um
but she stayed true to her word and we
shot a lot of stuff some of some of
those moments are in the film
but at the end of it
just didn't feel right to me to be
shooting it felt like she was so young
and vulnerable and she was going through
a really hard time so we kind of both
mutually agreed that the time wasn't
right you know I couldn't get my head
around how do you
shoot something like that when I was
feeling like she was
going into a breakdown and she's so
young
um
and then in 2019
she came back to me and said I'm going
to Kenny at the end of the year and I've
been looking forward to this for years
will you shoot Kenya it's just going to
be on my website and the Charities
website and I said yes of course I'll do
that that sounds amazing
and I said but just this is it as an
experiment why don't I shoot a couple of
days before we go in a couple of days
after Kenya to see what your life's like
um and so she went great and I began
shooting and that very first day
I realized that wow now there's a movie
because this is a girl just fresh out of
treatment she's very much still in
recovery like in the first stages of it
you know they're still tweaking or
medicine and they're you know
and her team are being very protective
of her but she's desperate to
help others
um
and I was like this is fascinating
because it felt like she was on the
other side of it in a sense
so we just very like carefully began
shooting very small I didn't have
producers I
found this guy who's fresh out of
college and I taught him how to use a a
camera like a little DSLR in my dining
room I'm teaching him here's the 180
degree rule this is how you cover a
scene if you're by yourself and he's
like learning kind of on the job because
we started up that small it because I
didn't I couldn't promise anything I
certainly didn't want to
sell this before I had a sense of what
was what was developing and that's the
thing with Cinema verite I think it's
very difficult these days
to
to find Opportunities like that but
luckily she was she was really open to
doing it and then as we kept shooting I
started realizing okay this is
interesting and I think Kenya is going
to be a part of this but it's not the
full story
and that's when you know
the
um the record label and your managers
were like okay maybe we'll spend a
little
real money on this and it it became kind
of bigger but it really was like a labor
of love especially those first you know
few months
but
footage did you end up shooting and then
in addition to that you have the
archival footage so now you're starting
to put the story together this this was
um this is pretty
amazing I had 200 hours of footage of
Selena
and then she gave me all of her home
videos all of her photographs and then
towards the end she she I said to her
towards the end I was like you you're
constantly journaling do you think you
could find maybe 10 entries that you
want to share with me
and she went I actually want you to read
all of them
that should give me two huge boxes so
that alone took me like two weeks and
then constantly going back to that to
figure out like how do I use the right
bits but you know I was saying this to
Jazz I kind of believe
that a director in cinema verite is a
bit like an archaeologist like we know
that the story's there and we're just
trying to figure out what to let go of
in order for that single story to
um come to life and that was kind of our
approach but it took a long time it took
two years of solid editing yeah
you know you're following her around
she's very young as you said you know
she's just on the other side
um
how did you know like when to stop
you know filming such as like for the
lupus flare-up or like other moments
where you're like I need to get this
people need to see this well you know it
was interesting because by that point we
were really com she was really committed
I mean we both were in terms of saying
like we're doing this to help other
people and and by that point she and I
were really close I was like an older
brother to her and
um when I went to shoot on the day for
Lupus I was just going to get some
b-roll of her like hanging out in the
house and I heard that she wasn't doing
well and and so I knocked on the door
and I first went in
and talked to her and then she came out
and she was crying and like her
assistant had just walked in and she's
talking
and I and she said you can film this she
goes I want you to film this and I said
really and she was like yeah yeah and
you can see me I'm shooting with my
iPhone and I'm hugging her
and you know she talks about this a lot
of times you know I also would know when
I had enough of of that beat
and I would stop and I would return to
just being present for her you know like
the scene where she's crying in the
beginning of the film at um after the
dress rehearsal that was like my first
week of shooting
I was with her for 10 minutes by herself
in that dressing room talking to her
encouraging her saying this is this is
normal you know all artists are
perfectionists but it's not real what
you're feeling and holding her hand and
you know I even said like
you know the lights were all way up my
crew was there but we weren't filming
and I said um I said if you want I can
take the cameras out and she was like no
it's okay
but you build that rapport with the with
the subject where they almost feel like
the camera is an extension of you and
they want you there
that's what we did
um what was the most challenging part
during the edit process like and how
involved was she too
in that you know it was it was again
magical she wasn't involved she like
really just let me do it but it took a
long time uh and we had a two hour 20
minute version of this
and the label and and management were
like we love this this is great this is
or you know fantastic and you know it
went
to different places and and whatever and
I was like I said to myself I watched it
with Selena she didn't even say anything
I was like it's not done yet Selena
because I realized like it was delving
too much into the darkness without the
sinus wave was incorrect you know that
kind of the up and down uh as the story
unfolded wasn't correct
um and that's the part that takes a lot
of careful
um work you have to try different things
you know at points we had more journal
entries then I was like this is getting
in the way of the verite and you know
you you I was really experimenting but
um but she never came into the edit room
in terms of like
uh here are my notes she never gave me
notes
um I showed her the long cut
I was like it's not ready yet I'm gonna
ask for another probably a year because
by the way it's it's also impossible to
get editors these days because there's
so many docu series and
stuff happening that editors are booked
so I would get an editor and he might be
able to give me three months so you know
we were just constantly
having to shift but she gave me
um an incredible amount of freedom and
I'm lucky because Madonna did the same
and so I think I think I've been blessed
both these times by artists who who kind
of trusted in my vision but also they
knew that my heart was aligned with
theirs like I don't want to make a movie
that's a gotcha movie you know I fall in
love with my subjects
uh generally and that's
you you can see that when you watch the
documentary as you know I love the
opening I also love the ending with the
affirmations and talk about you know by
the way they cut the last scene in the
movie I don't know why they stopped this
film because what happens after those
end titles is she goes into the
recording Ruth and she she talks to the
writers who co-wrote the song with her
about like using her journals and you
hear her sing the song and you realize
that every variation of music you heard
in this song is a variation of her of
her song My Mind in me
um but sorry well you can offer this you
cannot go home and watch it and seek it
out it's it yes it's a beautiful tune
but um
yeah like talk how did you know you had
your ending like I I knew I had my
ending when she went to Texas she was on
her way to to shoot only murders in the
building and I already knew that that
was like starting to get into a
different chapter
but in the on the trip to New York she
stopped in Texas and that encounter
happened with that neighbor with that
little kid and I'm like this is the
ending of my film
you know she's seen basically herself as
as a as kind of a seven-year-old you
know and she has that moment where she
can almost you know hug that that girl
and and relate to her and
and you know she's walking off I was
thinking like okay I'll use like journal
entries I'll use you know these
affirmations and stuff that I that I'd
found in there
and you know we wrote voice over and I
knew that should be the ending and then
as we're editing she went to the White
House and I was like there are my end
you know and chiron's
you know it is
it's hot it's hot it's a hard watch
right we all know who Selena Gomez is we
didn't know her story you know we we
didn't know very much about it talk
about what it was like for you as a
filmmaker to go on this journey with her
but also be there as a human being when
she's having those moments you kind of
said you know like you felt like a big
brother but like what was that like you
know it really changed me making this
movie fundamentally changed who I was
um foreign
you know in the beginning it was very
difficult to shoot because I'm still
like in that mindset of like I I have
today I you know I have like three
people I have no money like we have to
shoot something today and she doesn't
want to get out of bed
and then
and then I it I slowly let that go
and
and as I became closer to her I was like
maybe I'll just shoot that she's not
getting out of bed
you know or maybe I'll so I just started
shooting everything and then
you know we became closer still
and I saw what an amazing human being
she was I really there were moments
where I just was like she could be going
through whatever but whenever she was
interacting with real people
whether it was make a wish there was an
amazing Make-a-Wish scene that we we
shot I couldn't use it
um
and that's when she would come alive and
I realized this is a girl who is not a
pop star like this it almost felt like
she was you know touched by God like she
she had been given you know one issue
after another but each time she was
trying to use it for good and I and I
became kind of progressively awed by her
um and then Kenya really just you know
again that that was life-changing for me
as well to see
the purity of What happiness
and joy
looks like
um
and
and so yeah it it really changed me as a
filmmaker but even more so as a person
yeah the Kenya scene is beautiful it's
it's heartbreaking too because of what's
what you know what they discussed there
but talk about like the you know the
other voices that you know that you were
gonna involve and include in the
documentary and how that how you
navigated that like which other voice
yeah like what though like her mom well
the mom was the final person that I
convinced that was a very tricky one
because
you know for both Selena and her mom
reliving any of this stuff is
you know can is borderline triggering so
that was asked at the very end you know
I showed her little bits I told her that
she's brought up by Selena so often and
you know I think the mother felt like
I've been vilified by the Press you know
already and am I putting myself back out
there and I said you know I it would
mean the world to me and it would it
would explain the story and I think it
it would let you address that idea that
you and your daughter don't get along
it's very difficult to be a parent of
someone suffering
at that level who who cuts you off at
some point
um but they had reconciled and they were
becoming closer so by the end I got that
little interview
um yeah I'm so glad you talked about the
music talk about the music that you
would use in the documentary and like
the
well when I heard my mind in me
um it was probably to me as a demo and I
was like this is the song and this
should be the title
um
and then I was like what do I want to do
for music
and I was at someone's house and they
had like background music on and I was
like what's that music you're playing
and they said oh here's the playlist
it's from Pandora and
and it was this
person called slow Meadow and I'm like
who's slow Meadow and so I started
looking them up and turns out it's
fronted by one guy
so I set to Interscope and the producers
um I was like we have to find this guy
he's gonna he's gonna do all the music
for this movie and they thought I had
really lost my mind at that point
they're like what are you talking about
and I said just trust me this is the guy
I could feel that he had this ability to
create atmosphere there is music and I
found him me as manager was in Alabama
he he works out of his garage in Houston
and he was you know you can imagine his
shock when you know
um I said you know I think you need to
do the composing for my film on Selena
Gomez and he looked like a deer caught
in red lights on the zoom and um
and at first he was nervous
and he was doing his thing and I was
like you're you're trying way too hard
like I want you to think of the next two
months like you're playing in a sandbox
I'm gonna give you this track and I want
you to experiment with it and do
variations so I'd be like can you give
me a seti version of of the song Can you
now do a waltz and he'd like do a waltz
like live on his little piano
and I'd be like can you give me the
waltz in a minor key you do that and you
know so it was this wonderful experience
where I was like seeing this this this
guy's talent and anyway editors were
like is this guy a Reincarnation of set
tea or something because he was so
proficient and that he would record he'd
bring a friend in to play the viola and
another friend to play the bass in his
garage and that's who we use and it just
felt more authentic and the idea that my
mind and me
it's a very beautiful track
and the variations almost became the
different moods of Selena
I love that it is a beautiful score and
a beautiful
um song okay
so you know as you as you know and I've
said this to you before you know it's so
great to see you making movies again
um has this what your appetite to be
like maybe I'm not gonna wait so long
before my next movie or documentary like
um yes it has you know I I think I got
over the hump of I never wanted to make
another documentary because Truth or
Dare felt like lightning in a bottle and
I and I realized like I really do enjoy
it I have to be careful I don't think I
can give another six years of my life to
something
um it really took a lot out of me and I
changed and it was an important period
of change but yeah I do feel like I'm
entering maybe chapter three
of my life and I would like to do more
it's very difficult because there's so
much content and I was telling jazz
even finding the crews of the caliber
that you want them to be editors
whatever it's
It's Tricky so yes I want to do work but
I want to do good quality work
and so it'll be a question of you know
hopefully having those opportunities
watch the space okay last question
um what do you want the audience to take
home tonight on this
you know I I'd have to go back to our
original purpose in making it and
and that is you know if you feel that
there's anybody in your life
that might get something from this film
is just to spread the word that's really
all I care about I'm not really after
Awards or publicity or anything like
that it just
you know we're all very well I'm
certainly privileged you know I think
we're privileged to certain egregious
living in this country
and um there's so much darkness and I
just would love to try to bring a little
more light
into the world and into our time right
now so yeah that would be my
my biggest desire you know but obviously
that's up to everyone's own conscience
okay so you have homework
spread the wood and go home and finish
the rest watch the end of this and
listen to my mind to me because it's
incredible oh thank you for coming out
thank you so much thank you everybody
for coming out and thank you to Apple
too
foreign
[Music]